[Music]
I'm looking for Matt and I don't know if
you're the right map but I need to speak
to you right now please
okay we'll go to the email to find some
people that are seeking advice on
various different issues in their life
this is from Isaac says dear sweet daddy
the guest preacher at the last worship
service my College's Ministry holds
spoke about the Apostle Paul's message
in First Corinthians chapter 8 about how
a married person's attention is divided
between God and their spouse and so Paul
says it is better to remain single the
preacher and his wife of 18 years and
encouraged us to enjoy singleness and to
not rush to get married too soon however
I have also read past years about how
it's good to get married and I'm having
trouble reconciling these two sentiments
should I wait to see a wait to seek a
wife until I'm older and how soon a
relationship is too soon for marriage in
your opinion how soon is too soon you
know that that until that question comes
up in every uh every segment we do but I
I've I've said you know I think six
months for engagement is like there's no
exact time frame and I'm biased because
I'm only telling you what happened for
me but um I think six months is enough
time to discern that you want to get
engaged and then you get engaged and but
you don't need to be engaged for five
years either as though Pastor said you
know I think that it's at the best naive
in the extreme uh unhelpful you know in
this environment to be talking to young
people so you said you're a college
student right so you're a young adult
and just have the message be enjoy enjoy
singleness I certainly hope there was at
least more to it than that it's not so
easy for especially from everything that
I that I hear from single people all the
time that are looking for someone it's
you know to to just enjoy it and enjoy
being alone especially when when most of
us have this longing to find a companion
that's very natural and to just say oh
just enjoy enjoy being single out in
this decaying Society of ours so I think
that's at best naive and it's also a
misinterpretation of that particular
passage of First Corinthians this is a
very specific situation a moment in time
not not that it has no application
outside of that but he's talking to
people in a specific situation
um that I don't think is intended for
you to be taken as a as a young adult in
modern American 2023
um I don't think that that verse is the
Apostle Paul telling you that it's
better if you don't get married there
are some people who are called to that
where you are called to a life of
service outside of marriage but for most
people that's not your vocation that's
not what you're called to you should
discern whether that's the case but it
sounds like for you you know you know
you want to get married eventually so
that's not the case for you also in that
same uh verse well not mistaken I could
look it up but like right after saying
that he also mentions that
even in that context someone that in
which he was writing if not getting
married is going to lead you into to sin
um you know into sexual sin it was now
you're having sexual relations outside
of marriage and that sort of thing if
that's where it's going to lead you to
then it's better to get married you know
he even says that in that Passage
um and I don't think that that's the
only reason to get married but it is
also true trying to be chaste and
observe biblical sexual morality as a
young single adult modern America it's a
very difficult thing and to just think
that's good and for a pastor to say well
do that indefinitely
um is not very practical I don't think
it's good advice man that's some bad
advice so I think already as a as a
young adult you know you're thinking
about marriage and you get into the
dating scene with that in mind and it
doesn't mean that the first person you
go on a date with you're gonna get
married to it's just that that's the end
goal you have in mind and you are you
know it's like a it's a mutual job
interview for you I'm fine
are you fine
you're fine then
where you are seeing if each other are
the right fit for for marriage down the
line but it's important to have that end
goal in mind to know so you're dating
with a purpose you know what this is
supposed to be leading to you know the
kind of standard that you're that you're
looking for and there's no reason why
you can't start thinking about that
right now you know it takes a special
kind of company to want to partner with
my show I say a lot of things that make
a lot of people angry and this tends to
scare off advertisers that's why I'm so
grateful to Partners like pure talk who
stand behind me and my show no matter
the consequences they might face Pure
Talk shares my values which is why we've
made them the official cell phone
wireless partner of the daily wire
that's not the only reason Pure Talk
offers the most Dependable 5G Network in
the US I use it myself their plans are
top tier but at a fraction of the cost
of ATT Verizon or T-Mobile you get
unlimited talk text and unlimited data
with a mobile hotspot for just 55 a
month you vote with how you spend your
money so stop supporting woke wireless
companies that don't support you instead
go to puretalk.com Walsh you'll get
great coverage and save while you're at
it you go to Walsh you'll save an
additional 50 off your month because
they actually value you that's
puretalk.com
Wireless for Americans buy Americans
Rachel says hi Matt I'm in the military
currently stationed overseas and I'll be
getting stationed in Alaska three months
from now
I'm in a relationship with a man that I
could see myself spending the rest of my
life with but he has sent he was sent to
be stationed in the Southeastern U.S a
few months ago uh he will still we still
talk on the phone nearly every day since
he left and we watch movies and shows
together on video chat we send each
other books to read and songs to listen
to All of which I'm beyond grateful for
but I'm so scared that the distance will
eventually cause us to drift apart and
I'll lose them forever he's given me no
reason to think this way he always
expresses that he misses me and that he
loves talking to me and he's even told
me that he doesn't want to lose me
either I'm trying to just enjoy every
moment I share with him but there are
times that the fear of losing is too
overwhelming do you have any advice or
push for pushing past this fear or on
keeping a law this relationship strong
over a long period of time I think it's
sort of similar advice to what I just
gave I think that uh I don't know how
long you guys were dating before you
ended up being sent to different parts
of the world in any dating situation
it's important to have that end goal in
mind and for you both to understand that
that's what you're working towards is
eventually getting engaged and getting
married if either one of you has has
ruled that out as a possibility or or
you have no interest in even thinking
about marriage right now then that's
something that should be communicated to
the other because that means that this
is a relationship doomed to fail and
it's probably better just cut it off now
cut it out get out get out of here or
you can hang on until the Heartbreak
comes down the line so that's that's the
case in any dating relationship but I
think especially in a situation like
this where you guys are time zones apart
um it's important to have that end goal
in mind so I would start you know
talking about that if you haven't
already and I think that gives you your
best chance when you when you both know
where this is leading what you want for
the future it's not like this open-ended
so you're having an open-ended ambiguous
kind of relationship is potentially
fatal to the relationship in any context
but especially when you're not even
physically around each other
so that's one thing I'll certainly do
all right
um we'll leave it there for today
[Music]
[Applause]